hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to getting over it with
Bennet Fadi I've calmed down a bit I'm a
drink that I have spilled cheers y'all
mmm not gonna put any liquid on the desk
of which I am raging everything's fine
so we're gonna make it up this mountain
I did so much better during the
livestream I did I did so much better
during the lecture
well not not like climbing wise but just
like emotionally wise for some reason
for some reason and I don't know why I
really don't I don't know why ah
that last part there was just the
biggest piece of [ __ ] to me oh boy but
I'm gonna get through this next area
with lots of candor whoa ah and less
volatile emotions which is the key to
success just like that okay but this
next part is a bit of a [ __ ] isn't it
yeah oh no it's not
I got it unlock yeah yeah winner winner
me dinner okay all right yep it means a
lot to me that you've come this far
endured this much it's not a wisecrack
shut up the sensitivity shut up
every sit back
[Music]
I forgot where the ass of the Snowman
was
[Music]
please tell me I can get through this
just fine
I forgot the ass of the Snowman
I forgot that yes okay it's fine no
[Music]
piece of [ __ ] you moonwalking [ __ ] stick
I want I want to like a scientist to
analyze the physics of what the hell
just happened when I slid 10 [ __ ]
miles backwards propulsion but I was
propelled at like the speed of light
backwards
I had my hammer in the ground the whole
time and no traction and I get that it's
ice and all but that was why did that
happen but that was just god damn
[ __ ] and this game knows it no I
hate this mouse but I hate this mouse by
the way I is of course I'm gonna blame
the mouse because it's a different Mouse
than the one I had been practicing with
for 24 hours that's how long I've played
this game for and I haven't been don't
you moon slide oh don't you moon slide
on me don't you moon slide oh no no no
no not today no nope all right this is
gonna be the one I say is a carefully
planned floor
myself okay yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
baby oh yes baby yeah
why no I don't know how that worked but
it did and I'm happy I'm sooo slow down
slow that rolls whoa that roll
I'm so happy that it did because I am a
happy camper in this happy camper
is going to market alright ok now where
are you is that my I don't know what I
was doing yeah yeah I'm sliding here I
go to the but here no no you slimy butt
[ __ ]
you sly d bud [ __ ] okay we're back
again here to get this one yeah that's
easy now hmm easy peasy
easy peasy me easy peasy me okay now
where are you you but [ __ ] no come on
come on come on slightly but slightly
but gave me that slighty but okay
alright
that shouldn't have been that hard don't
know why it was hmm okay don't know why
this is so difficult
don't know why but I'll try I'm such a
nice guy
oh god why don't I just go buy a [ __ ]
new Mouse this mouse is broken you don't
know [ __ ] bag okay or is it shitty
little thrust I am NOT fool I am NOT
fool watch ha there no stop do big boy
thrust hmm oh that was fun and weird why
you go million-mile there why you
million-mile man there big boy thrust
easy easy easy
life is easy when you breezy and
beautiful [ __ ] yeah no not LIF no to
slide no no no no no no no no no no god
[ __ ] ducking ah [ __ ] shitty little
o [ __ ] Joseph in my top hat like a
[ __ ] magician
no what why why why why why why did you
do that
ha ha ha ha just set down there we go
that's good good very good
hook back on the slippery [ __ ] but you
know was I not I feel like I wasn't
doing okay yeah I feel like I wasn't
doing the pushy ah fee I was doing the
swing swap what I was doing oh shut the
[ __ ] up oh shut the [ __ ] up why did I
change why I had no reason to change
what I was doing I had no reason there
was no reason in the world to ah yes
shut up shut up shut up shut up shut up
shut up shut up oh my god are you
[ __ ] kidding me no no no no no no why
why why why
god I hate this Mouse I hate it so much
I hate it so much everything is fine
everything is fine everything is fine
everything is fine everything is fine
everything is fine no no so hard it's a
[ __ ] jump it's just a jump it don't
play music it's just a jump it's just
it's just a jump it's just a [ __ ]
jump it's it's just a [ __ ] jump
oh god of me no progress I've made no
progress
oh come no please I'm so angry I'm
so angry I'm so angry I'm right there
I'm right [ __ ] fair no no no my god
really really I don't [ __ ] understand
you and I know it's this mouse I know it
is I know it's the [ __ ] Mouse no I'm
right there no it's not a sensitivity
thing I've got the mouse sensitivity low
as [ __ ] balls I'm gonna make it lowers
shittier balls it's gonna be so low and
shitty the low shitty balls oh [ __ ]
now I've got a relearn please please
please please please please please
please please please please please just
put me down okay okay okay
there we go there we go there we go
there we go there we go
yes yes yes yes yes sound the horn of
success II Wasi don't know why I decide
I broke it I didn't break it
I broke my spirit no no please just let
this be a bad dream
let this be a [ __ ] bad dream why was
that such a Wimpy baby No okay I'm done
I'm done I'm done I'm done I'm done
that's it for this episode I can't do
this anymore I can't knowing this Oh
Popeye you so much Abraham Lincoln oh
[Music]
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know he big manly comes alone as
always no see you bye bye
[Music]